mónica I guess I want to start with the
origins of the movie and how it all got
started and I'm curious when did you
first hear Brian banks story and what
was the process like of trying to talk
him into doing a movie about it
well actually Amy Baer my producing
partner heard about Brian's story and
contacted him and then sort of had a
moment actually this is her story to
tell but she couldn't be here today but
she went to in between contacting him
and hearing about it she went and was a
on a jury and she actually had a moment
where she realized that the person who
had been accused of this crime was
actually innocent and she sort of left
that jury you know situation where he
was found innocent but and went and
called him reached out to Brian and got
his life rights and I think because she
wanted to make a movie about him and not
something that you know not a sports
movie not you know really just about who
he was as a person she won him over you
know and Justin so I came to it after
she told me she told me the story and
Shivani Rawat my producing part our
other producing partner the two of us
went and met Brian and as soon as we met
him he's such a light he's such a beauty
he's such a driving force that there was
no way we weren't going to make this
movie
what's your starting point do you talk
to Brian banks do you start reading
everything you can about the case I mean
I guess even going backwards a little
bit how did you first come onboard and
then what were your first steps toward
writing the screenplay
well the starting point actually began
with this Academy because I want a
nickel fellowship a while back for a
script I wrote called a keel in the be
there may be some Nikhil fellows here
today and because of the recognition
that I got from the nickel fellowship I
was eventually able to get that movie
made in a DVD for that film found its
way into the prison cell of Brian banks
he watched the movie when he was in a
very challenging place and when I met
with him he told me that it gave him
hope and that laid a foundation for us
to start building trust and start
listening to each other
primarily me listening to him I conveyed
to him a story about somebody very close
to me that had gone through something
similar to what he'd gone through and
you know Brian's a producer on the movie
with Monica and Amy and the relationship
gelled and it worked so I did do a lot
of research I had his whole case file at
every deposition every police report
every transcript but really for me the
Bible was the 12 hours of video that I
shot of Brian in New York when he was
working in the NFL front offices and the
three hours that I shot with Justin and
the trip that I took to San Diego I
think some of us on this stage took that
trip to sit in on his wrongful
conviction class but listening to Brian
for those 12 hours where he told me his
life from birth all the way up to the
point where we were sitting in that room
and I just needed to listen and feel
what he told me because Brian just
doesn't tell you here are the events he
says this is how I felt about this and
this was my perception of this event at
age 16 at age 17 at age 18 and my job
was to really try to feel that and then
put it in an order that makes sense so
that the folks up here could feel those
things so that these folks could feel
those things this is your first
narrative film in something like 10
years so I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about what you'd been
doing during that time and how it
informed not only your decision
to take Brian banks on as your sort of
return to the director's chair but how
it informed the actual movie and your
approach to it okay ten years how much
time you guys good
we're nobody's doing anything I'll I'll
give you the cliff notes on it I was
teaching and got drawn to Memphis
Tennessee from some family connections
and fell into a neighborhood that shook
me awake the urgency of which you
intuited and felt of which I told the
story was authentic because I had seen
this story happened to kids that I
taught that I cared about that were
thrust into the criminal justice system
and that system that conveyor belt is
conviction it's not about getting the
truth out that's what we all think most
of us who come from a privileged
relatively privileged background
affluent background that the truth is
going to come out it's not that system
that's why the statistic 97 percent of
cases plead out that means ninety seven
percent of people are being threatened
with a longer sentence if they will just
say they're guilty even when they're not
so we don't even know how many people
are innocent or some version and nuanced
story that we have never heard in our
criminal justice system and when you
feel it personally when you get close
you want to you want to tell a story
about it that's what we do we tell
stories and so look it's not like I had
been in retirement for 10 years I got
sick about 13 years ago and then took me
a couple years to heal I had a bad
concussion but I was trying to get work
and I just think it was a life's way of
saying you got to reinvent yourself Tom
you got to go experience something you
got to grow a little bit before you tell
the next iteration of stories that
you're gonna tell well I noticed in the
end credits that said the movie was shot
in Tennessee is that because of you or
was that some sort of tax incentive was
it cheaper to do it there what was that
all of this is true but it's it's mostly
because of the grace of Monica Shivani
and Amy who agreed that I presented them
with this opportunity if we're a movie
about social justice why don't we be
a version of social justice as we do
this movie and they said yes as long as
we could get
you know the relatively the same savings
so what you may not have noticed is we
mentor we shot this the production
offices were in one of the most
disenfranchised neighborhoods in America
South Memphis a specific town called
Soulsville believe it or not true name
and we mentored 30 kids on the movie
young people that I had known through
the University of Memphis and historical
black college that I taught at called
lemoyne-owen and that experience that
exposure has changed these kids lives
and it's changed I think our lives
because we all want to be a part of this
uplift show business look you know
showbiz an amazing thing storytelling is
amazing thing but we lock ourselves
behind gates and then we wonder why we
get disconnected from audiences and and
this was our way of opening a gate and
saying please we want to feel your
experience we want to learn from you and
if we have something to impart let's
let's let's go on this journey together
so now Manik has got you know of the
interns and Amy's got interns in her
office and opportunities are showing up
and we hope that can happen on many more
Sheri I read that you also had a
personal connection to this story and
were very you know really chased it you
really wanted this part and I'm curious
what it was that you responded to and
what kinds of conversations did you have
with Tom and the producers to kind of
convince them that you were the person
for this this movie you know when I read
the script I connected to Leo me who was
Brian bangs his mother her faith was so
strong for her son and my son at the
time was 12 years old and I said this
could be Brian banks by the end of the
script that duck had written I was in
tears and I said to my agent you've got
to get me an audition but the very thing
that I'm known for which is comedy kind
of worked against me in this because
they kept saying this lady named Viola
that's what everybody kept saying some
lady named Viola that name was being
bandied about and I wasn't able to get
an audition and then I did get an
audition and I didn't hear from anybody
for a few weeks so I didn't think I got
it and they said Tom you were cleaning
your computer
you found my tape you did isn't that
funny how God works but I had a FaceTime
audition with with Tom and I told him
how I advocate for my son who has
special needs and how I had to fight for
my child and and I had a FaceTime with
Monica and Amy and the same thing and I
knew and and you know it only takes one
person to believe in you and that was
Tom Shadyac who I just said I'm so
grateful for Monica and Amy because he's
worked with Eddie Murphy and he wrote a
movie for Eddie Murphy and he's worked
with Jim Carrey and so when he said I
had to sit on Jim I think I'll have to
sit on you I was like I've been waiting
for somebody to sit on me my whole life
and this was Tom and so I'm so grateful
that he saw I don't know what he saw but
that he saw something because I wanted
it really badly really really badly I
just connected with Leo me as a mother
as a woman of faith as an advocate and a
mother who was fearful for her child
now Greg you've worked in a lot of
movies where you've played real people I
mean Bob Crane Kennedy does that scent
do you first of all do you feel an added
sense of responsibility when you're
playing somebody real and if so how does
that affect your approach you know how
does it affect you approaching something
like this and and how much contact did
you have with the real Justin so Justin
is you know was available to me you know
kind of early on in the process he was
he was and through the process he and
Brian were were with us on the set
pretty much like every day there were
scenes where Brian would would step away
because it was what Aldous was going
through or you know it was just too
intense a few times but but Justin was
there and he invited me down to San
Diego and he teaches at the California
Western School of Law and he let me sit
in a couple of his classes and you know
I went to
the CIP California Innocence Project he
was nice enough to let me in there and
just hang out with the the gang but no I
don't know I felt like I just I liked
this story so much and obviously for the
very reasons that you're I think
everybody up here is expressing how
value how much value there is in this
film so I was you know taken with all
aspects of it didn't really know the
details of it and didn't know what the
California Innocence Project was and how
they had you know they had exonerated
over 30 people the innocent people you
know not not on technicalities but you
know truly innocent people who this
organization without Justin overtaking
of dime goes in with these law students
and does this and I was so taken with
that and and so I guess there was a
course I wanted you know you want to get
some sense of the guy but I there's no
obligation he's I can say it cuz Justin
isn't here the entire country doesn't
know him but you know I I do think that
you know for me what was really
interesting was that they get the first
thing I saw in their office was just a
piles of letters letters just people
saying please help me and it's
heartbreaking and you think of him
starting at that point the character you
know forget the reality the character
starting at that point of truly wanting
to help people truly wanting to reach
out and lend a hand this was a little
unusual you know Brian was out of jail
he you know he had he's wearing an ankle
bracelet and he's he's on parole so in a
way I think in talking to Justin I felt
like you know the way that it started
was well this was a guy who you know was
a bad situation but my god he's so much
better off than so many other people and
in that turn of Brian advocating for
himself and and Brian making himself
known was what was really cool to Justin
so that that shift of him was was the
the thing that was was fun to play I
want to thank all of you for coming and
talking with us about it's a beautiful
movie